oh my god you look so incredibly
beautiful tonight tonight tonight
I think it's amazing and I think that
Brooklyn has always been an iconic and
also Brun breaking friend they've been a
huge support supporter and advocate for
women whether if it's through the
campaign's that they've done with
Charlie for the perfume Charlie when she
wore the Pens
back in the 70s or through their
philanthropic work and I'm very very
happy to be part of this family
I'm we are we're all very moved by the
feedback that we receive from the from
the fence and honestly we've never done
this movie for the Oscars that wasn't
our objective our objective was to make
a movie that people would love and enjoy
and be inspired by and you can't have it
all I mean the movie was received in
such an incredible way that were just
grateful and humble for the way that it
was received and we're doing another one
so who knows maybe of the second one I
don't know absolutely not
know do they want more lipstick or more
Wonder Woman lipstick lipstick although
I must say that my daughter plays with
Barbie dolls of them
you yeah I do complete separation we
call them Diana
although the boy is Chris Pine and it's
not Steve Trevor funny but yes she loves
both tonight thank you so much